welcome back to new rockstars the
multiverse of madness that is going to
consume doctor strange is going to have
him facing demons magic wielders
interdimensional beings mutants and even
variations of himself with a longer
beard and uh you know it's another one
that has his life together i guess was
nice and red and has nice nice facial
hair it looks really nice defender
strange but who's the real villain here
when did movies get so damn confusing
just tell me who the villain is marvel
which why why why the confusion i need
to know this is rogue theory the show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we adore my name
is mt and going the road with me today
is every villain's number one fan it's
jessica clemens what's going on just
because i'm their number one fan i love
them
are you daddy fan fans number one friend
i know that you don't don't even give me
something just started on that don't get
me started oh i'm sweating oh i'm
sweating
he's sweating too
and kicking star-shaped holes all over
this dimension it's whitney then landing
him yeah
oh man that's because i wear cool boots
all the time hey
you got that america chavez boots all
right i got to see us you those air
chavez's i got you i'll help you and uh
oh my god here's i guess that's just a
converse because that's just a star
because oh yeah
yeah
and the one person who knows the truth
but is refusing to tell us it's
off-screen producer brandon oh yes
that's right i know the truth of all but
it's not time to tell you guys yet
because you're not ready until me and
the other illuminati say it's time to
tell you the truth then we'll tell you
the truth but until then no truth for
you i got a lot of i got a lot of bones
to pick with you illuminati and then
you'll have to like drag me in in
handcuffs in order to tell me the truth
that's why we call him off-screen
producer brandon it's because uh he's
off screen with the illuminati off
screen from the universe you know just
planning off screen off world you know
what i mean that's right
we got a great cafeteria you wouldn't
believe it
[Laughter]
ultron botched the service food all day
it's our favorite foods it's the best
dude honestly i've never thought about
like the cafeteria at the church of
scientology but that has to be
nuts right
really i feel like it's better than what
the stormtroopers have to deal
with i feel like stormtroopers have the
worst cafeteria oh for sure on a scale
of stormtrooper to scientology how good
is your calf you know that's what i'm
trying to find out here today i'm only
joining one organization and i need to
know who has the best lunch i feel like
it probably looks like the futuristic uh
restaurant that squidward went to in
that when he went to the future
you are 100
accurate
yes that is exactly what it is my life
is just spongebob references anyway
as we continue to go frame by frame
through the recent doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness trailer we keep
coming back to one major question and
that leads us to our first topic of the
day who is the real villain going to be
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness it's gonna be wanda maximoff
mordo that ribbon monster that i hope i
hope is sleepwalker i really hope it's
sleepwalker kind of looks like sleep
parker but anyway a doctor strange
variant maybe but by looking at by
looking at all the clues in the recent
doctor strange trailer who do we think
is most likely to wind up being the real
big bad threatening the multiverse with
all of this madness taken away fellas
and ladies wolf what fella two ladies
otherwise it fellas oh that's my
favorite porno
anytime anybody ever says the phrase my
favorite porno i sing it in my head to
the theme song of my favorite murder
like my face
[Music]
[Laughter]
i i'll go i'll go first i ultimately
think um it's so hard to
um it's so hard to choose it's so hard
to choose because it's clear that it's
the multiverse of madness they're going
through different portals they're going
through different
different multiverses or whatever so i
think ultimately the real villain
is going to be doctor strange
and the most metaphorical sense of it
where it's like i think it's going to be
the evil version of him but it's going
to be like i am you you am i yeah like
you are i i think we're following
basically i think we're following the
what if series right so i think it's
gonna be that evil doctor strange in a
different universe is like causing a lot
of this but they're gonna slide into the
person instead of being the vision
uh ultron that we see it's gonna be
wanda i think wanda is gonna be the
vision ultron so take the what if series
and take out all of the things that it's
doing right now but then just think
about like instead of it being vision
ultron it's gonna be wanda and wanda is
gonna be the one chasing them through
the portals but the person that started
all of this will ultimately be doctor
strange so i think the villain
is in a weird like heart-shaped box is
within doctor strange but it the actual
villain is like wanda
does that make sense okay wait so
wait
wait hold on let me drop it a little bit
because i'm lost
let me write it down right now okay so
here's doctor strange
here's his little beard and his eyes no
okay so
okay
you know think of any disney movie where
it's like it was or think of the wizard
of oz um it was you had the ability to
go home all along it was in your heart
but instead of being the heart and being
going home think of it being a villain
and being evil doctor strange is half
himself is doing evil stunts and that
evil stunts is the evil doctor strange
that we see in the what if series so i
think that dr strange is a real person
in a different multiverse
and is going off and being crazy and
essentially releasing the or giving the
like idea to the
evil wanda the wanda that's just gonna
destroy everything so i think the
physical villain is wanda but i think
the like like the person behind the
strings
the
puppet master is the evil doctor strange
does that
i think that would have been easier just
to say is that wanda's pinocchio in the
evil puppet geppetto is dr strange the
evil doctor strange that we've been
seeing the evil doctor strangers that
we've been seeing i think that there's
an evil doctor strange in the background
just manipulating events yeah i think
well because that's what it is in the
what if series it's the whole like oh
ultron wouldn't have came out if he
didn't see that the watcher existed like
the watcher kept appearing and he was
like there's something beyond this world
that i'm in so i think that person is
vision or is uh the evil doctor strange
being like wanda there's more behind
there you can keep tearing it down let
me get out of here [ __ ] like sort of
just like speaking to her from like the
from the mirror dimension or something
be like hello
do bad things do hood rat things with
your friends
yeah go and destroy everything for me
and then emperor palpatine is the evil
doctor strange there's so many
characters to it and i know that wanda i
was like it's everyone versus wanda but
i think wanda's being puppeteered by
someone and not puppeteered but mainly
just being like ushered into all of this
[ __ ] chaos in some way or another and
who's ushering that has to be the evil
doctor change that we see in the trailer
okay interesting i like that theory okay
and evil strange in the darkness i like
that what do you guys got brandon well i
you know i've been a big supporter of
the fact that our doctor strange is the
bad doctor strange uh and i still kind
of think that in a lot of ways a bad guy
bad boy
yeah got that bad boy goatee that's how
you know he's like he's ready to put it
all risk anything kill anyone he's he's
willing to do it okay to keep himself
alive but what i think sure you know
with the inclusion of the illuminati now
and all that i have this theory that uh
you know our
mcu is at earth one nine nine nine nine
nine is is like dangerous it's it's not
just dr strange it's our whole what we
know as the mcu is dangerous to the
other multiverses because of the actions
they've taken to what they've done to
the infinity stones to what they've done
to an eternal to all this stuff
uh we're we're the dangerous ones and so
i think the truth that professor x is
going to tell doctor strange is like
look your universe is bad and it's
threatening all the universes
universe eye all the universal souls
and so we're gonna have to cut it off
we're gonna have to cut you guys off and
i'm so sorry that's the truth we're here
to give it to you and that's about it
you can stay here at our illuminati home
base we like you but we're gonna have to
just like cut you guys off and our
doctor strange is gonna be like oh hell
no uh and he's like he's the bad boy
he's the bad boy and what he's going to
do he's going to find a way to like
preserve our mcu and keep us all safe
spinning off
yeah in like its own little
self-contained thing okay he's going to
cut off the rest of the multiverses uh i
love it i think they're still gonna
exist but we're gonna he's gonna find a
way to separate the mcu
from it all so who's the big bad in this
in a way it's all of us uh combined but
uh because we as viewers humanity yeah
we as viewers like what the mcu does so
we're supporting it so we're also the
bad guys too uh so
the real villain are the friends we made
along the way you know it's like they're
gonna we're gonna cut off our mcu from
the rest of the multiverse uh and that's
that's gonna be the result i don't think
any multiverse is gonna die necessarily
but we're gonna be like completely cut
off and on our own somehow uh
and we'll have to find a way back and
that'll be part of like phase four it's
like finding a way back into the greater
quilt
of the multiverse but we're gonna get
cut off in this one doctor strange is
gonna do some crazy spell to completely
cut us off that is rogue my friend that
is very very rogue i do like that but it
means
just floating in our little ball
somewhere floating alone
honestly that's probably the thing it
will be we'll be on orion's belt right
and and men in black will be the little
charm
that'll probably be best for us because
we keep starting [ __ ] with every other
planet that we don't need to be starting
[ __ ] yeah yeah we're problematic
yeah we don't need to be you know we
don't need my biggest question for that
is like where the hell would um
where the hell would uh
uh
captain marvel go
where the hell would she be would she be
with us or would she just be like she
might she might be getting a [ __ ]
random place yeah she's like she found
the planet with the best cafeteria and
that's where the she's gonna stay there
like she's gonna stay there she chooses
things just like we here
right on this podcast do she's like can
i get a can i get a chicken sandwich
guys got a tuna sandwich over here sick
yeah
what you got whitney oh man uh i think
that it's definitely going to be
watermelon star fox harry styles i think
that he's going to be the big bad of the
multiverse of madness i think that it's
just gonna be too much and he's gonna
come down and be like everybody follow
in my direction there's only one
direction and then he's gonna take us
all and kill us um
no i have a real theory
but uh and it's a spoiler for a video
that i did that's coming out later uh so
i don't wanna spoiler myself
uh but it's i i do think uh so i'm gonna
i'm gonna mild mild spoilers
okay give us some sausage
like a little like like at taco bell
when you you're being a [ __ ] and you're
like i'll take the mild sauce that's the
level of spoiler i'm gonna give you um
so i do think that uh it would be really
interesting
to see
the house of m storyline come into the
mcu
via the multiverse of madness because we
do have professor x in the mix this is
something that like everyone has been
theorizing for a while just because
we're all like when when are mutants
getting here guys when they gonna show
up
um
so
a really interesting storyline from the
house of n comics is that
uh everyone thinks that uh
magneto is behind scarlet witch
destroying reality and messing with the
multiverse and messing with time and
stuff
and um
what ends up happening is that uh dr
strange has a little conversation with
her in the astral plane and finds out
that her twin brother pietro was
actually behind it the whole time
and i think that that would be a really
cool way to tie in pietro from
wandavision back to this that he's
actually the one pulling all the strings
um i think that that would be a really
cool thing if he's secretly whispering
in his sister's ear now that he's back
in our multiverse uh and controlling his
twin
i like that like he wants to stay alive
so bad he's like convincing her to like
do this yeah exactly yeah
i know i really do like that theory
because like in the comics awanda and
pietro are like so attached to each
other and like they they they love each
other so much and like in this almost
weird like possessive way so like i can
totally see a piece of just like being
like all right i need to be alive
because i need to keep my sister in
check because without me she's clearly
going to go crazy so like i could
totally see that being a scenario yeah
man i think it could be really cool yeah
i want wanda to be evil i like evil
wanda i like her as like a villain but i
also want her to have a lot of agency i
know that everyone's concerned about
that they don't want it to just be like
oh she's a crazy lady and she's acting
crazy yeah because that would suck
that's too cheap and honestly i do think
though that like
marvel's smart enough not to do that
because
yeah i i hope that they are because like
that would just be so
just
dumb and cheesy and just like no pick
something better
better ways to tell that story evil let
it be her decision and then when like
agatha finally comes back and it's like
see i tried to warn you guys she's bad
yeah that's just bad it's just because i
killed a pc listen
everybody's mad at me ever since i
killed that dog that one time
i had to do it for the song it sounded
good in the song so i had to do it okay
these are all excellent ideas i mean i
really do love the idea of you know
pietro potentially being and that is
super rogue i was not even considering a
pietro scenario but like
because of the comics like in like their
weird like i don't know kind of creepy
relationships sometimes in the comics
i'm just like what's going on here yeah
like in the comics they're definitely
like a little bizarre like like the ac
like the um the physical manifestation
of what their relationship in the comics
looks like is you know like those those
uh paparazzi photographs of mary kate
and ashley both wearing like long black
bag dresses just simultaneously smoking
cigarettes
walking like in a like straight line
together down the street like that's
their relationship but like
that's yeah you know and they've got a
really abusive father so i think it's
it's it's yeah like exactly
you know what i mean they've been lied
to most of their lives it's tough it's
tough magnetic man not very magnetic
personality
unless you're a terrorist
but
i don't know what i'm saying but no i
really do love that theory so for
whitney um six million rogue bucks for
you
yeah and brandon your theory about the
whole universe being sort of just bad or
just like something in our universe just
being wrong so that it could separate us
from all the other multiverse it makes a
lot of sense considering all the weird
stuff that has happened to the mcu and
all like the weird like cosmic events
that we've sort of avoided so far so i'm
going to give you another five million
bucks shout out as well
i give you a million billion so both of
you get five million each but
this idea of an evil doctor strange i
honestly feel could actually be the
actual ticket here because we've got a
lot of evil strange barriers we have at
least two other variants that we don't
really know too much about and they're
both kind of sketchy to me so for miss
jessica i'm going to give
six million uh rogue points because i
think that uh an evil doctor straight
into the shadows could be very likely
and like we see at the very end of the
trailer what the heck was that what was
that the alarm man with a little demon i
don't even know what that dark creature
was
so
no idea
it could be nice we shouldn't judge them
by the way
sweet
you don't know it's true
in his universe people might just look
like that okay
we're the ugly ones
these are all amazing answers and up
next we are going to talk about an
important character returning for season
two of loki but first our merch partners
at epic hero shop just released some
really cool merch designs inspired by
the batman they've got three new shirt
designs and two sock designs to choose
from and you better believe all those
shirts are available in black because
why wouldn't they be because you gotta
fight crime at night so people yeah so
you gotta wear this shirt yes it's
blacked up order now you can have them
by opening night so head on over to
epicheroshop.com to see the designs and
grab one for yourself or else you're
going to be missing out on some really
cool [ __ ] look at this peacemaker shirt
i'm wearing it's dope it's really dope
you're not you don't have it what's
wrong with you go to heroshop.com but
also our buddies at some basket deliver
healthy meals so that you aren't on the
hook to shop and cook in order to hit
your health goals sunbasket delivers the
joys of eating with bold flavors organic
produce and sustainable seafood and
meats their award-winning chefs are
constantly innovating with new recipes
and global tastes to keep it interesting
each week with dozens of options stop
suffering through sad lunches sun basket
has exciting new grain burrito and
noodle bowls for every day of the week
try black rice bibimbap or shishuan
glass noodles just heat and eat in
minutes and you can put dinner on
autopilot with easy to prep meal kits
that impress for date night or when over
the picky eaters in your family so
whether you eat vegetarian paleo gluten
free or low carb some basket has
something delicious for you set up
weekly delivery and skip a week when you
need to it's simple easy and you'll love
it and right now sunbasket is offering
90 off and a free gift when you order so
go to sunbasket.com
rogue and enter promo code rogue at
checkout at sunbasket.com
rogue and enter promo code rogue and our
friends at shutter are trying to keep
you flush in scary and thrilling content
by dropping all kinds of great stuff on
their streaming platform with shutter
you can stream supernatural thriller and
horror movies and tv shows across all
your favorite devices their library has
original movies like vhs 94 and the hit
series creep show by executive producer
greg nictero of the walking dead they've
got classes like the wicker man and new
movies like the last thing mary saw what
was the last thing mary saw are you
gonna have to find out by going to
shutter i don't know what it is it's
probably really scary it wasn't anything
uh
anything on nick jr and shutter has just
released an exclusive documentary called
woodlands dark and days bewitched it's
the ultimate history of the folk horror
genre and they even have a movie we're
big fans of called the invitation it's a
creepy culty movie directed by karen
kusama that's done a lot of really cool
tv directing work and i really recommend
you guys check it out so stream all this
and more from shutters ever growing
library ad free for just
5.99 a month what a low price to scare
your pants off so if you're a fan of
supernatural thriller and all things
horror you're going to love shutter as
much as i do and right now you can
stream your first 30 days of shutter for
free just go to shutter.com and use code
rogue that is s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com
code rogue to stream your first 30 days
of shutter for free shutter.com code
rogue in this winter upgrade your daily
routine with bespoke post and their
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke post
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you unique
goods every month in the past we've
gotten some awesome bar wear and
sweaters from bespoke post so no matter
what you're into box of awesome has you
covered from winter cocktails to cozy
threads and camping gear essentials box
of awesome has collections for every
part of your life they've got a box
called scorch that has hot sauces from
makers from all over the country that
would be a fun way to warm up on a
winter month so to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com and your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month and it's free to sign
up and you can skip a month or cancel
any time and each box costs only 45
bucks but has over 70 dollars worth of
gear inside with so it's a great deal
and plus with each box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses and get up
to 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code rogue at checkout that is
box of awesome.com code rogue for 20 off
your first box now while we've enjoyed
all the marvel limited series on disney
plus one of our favorites is getting a
second season and the news broke this
week that a major character is confirmed
to return which leads us to our second
topic of the day owen wilson is
confirmed for loki season two yes owen
wilson the man himself morbius will be
returning as mobius and i said morbius
yes
it's too confusing
what if owen wilson is the mcu's morbius
oh wow
i want to drink your blood oh wow
wow wow is this oh
brandon sounds like owen wilson when you
sound like jennifer coolidge
i know my jennifer coolidge is too close
to my owen wilson very close ah jeez
makes me want a hot dog real gosh
oh my gosh oh my god
all right so yes owen wilson will be
returning as mobius and mobius in season
two of loki which is set to begin
filming this summer we also know that
google and bottawa will reprise her role
as ravonna renslayer so knowing that the
series won't come out until probably
like for another year what do we think
season two could look like as the mcu
continues to go through major universal
and multiversal shifts well one thing
ravona said would she
exit a stage left even during the finale
of uh loki season two was that she's
gonna go find that free will right that
doesn't exist at all so she like eats
out of there uh and then everything
changes and we don't know where she is
right loki comes back to a a tva that's
totally different mobius doesn't
recognize him uh b-52 what's her name
b-39b
hunter-b
the
yeah so like she's out there and i
assume she's like unaffected by whatever
changes happened that like messed up
moebius's mind and and hunter b 52 or
whatever name is i apologize completely
uh
so like i think she's gonna be the real
dark horse and
we don't know how like everything's
gonna settle with like kang
between like ant-man and wasp quantum
mania and all that stuff i think she's
gonna be like really pissed and they
have the storyline in the comics that
they're like kind of lovers or they're
very close to each other i think they're
gonna subvert the expectation here and
she's gonna be like angry and not in
love with this [ __ ] uh and she's
gonna be out for like some answers and
when she doesn't get the answers she
likes she's gonna start killing kangs so
i see her as like
almost like omar on the wire going
around like stealing drugs from
everybody and killing everybody she's
going to be out there killing kangs
she's going to be the number one killer
uh and obviously that was gonna be my
theory i was gonna go with ravana bangs
king
i think they're gonna get it on
i mean he has been creeping on her from
afar for a very long time yeah no it's
it's true and uh yeah the comics they
have that little uh
tryst literally the weirdest romance of
all time like their whole like it's it's
so freaking weird let's look into it
it's the weirdest thing because like she
wants to kill him at one point and then
they're okay and then like there's
variance and then like she has to like
sacrifice herself and then
he keeps her like barely alive in
basically like a bacta tank
it's yeah it gets weird it gets there's
a weird storyline in there yeah it was a
weird couple of decades for comics for
women unfortunately i definitely think
that there's a big possibility that
ravenna red slayer could either be
banging kang or trying to kill kang
because she does both of those things
with the comics and it does make sense
for uh for for that to be a scenario for
sure yeah i'm i'm team both i'm team
bang and kill
she took she takes mary kill really
literally
and it's all the same person to her
marry and kill all the same merry and
kill every kang variant oh that's what
it is she has to go through every kang
variant and mary kill them
but irl okay that's my theory
brandon
i'm piggy backing off of you let's pray
that's fair i have her just killing you
have her with multiple options i like
the idea too that like it's just however
she's feeling that day she's like how am
i gonna treat this king today yeah what
am i gonna do with this one i'm feeling
nice i'd like to go on a date she has
multiple kang boyfriends oh my god that
would be amazing yeah yeah she's
stringing along kang's yo that would be
yeah that's that's a power move i'd
respect it uh what you got jess owen
wilson
um
our mobius doesn't
know what's happening like loki knows
everything and he doesn't so i think
there's gonna be the first episode of
them trying to
or at least half the first episode is
moby is getting his memory back or just
being immediately told what's going on
right now and somehow needs to win the
trust over with loki again so uh because
right now he doesn't really even know
who loki is he's just like what's going
on
this is my leader we've been watching
over this man forever he's our ruler so
i think we're gonna spend that first
episode and then it's gonna be them
trying to take down the kang variants
like brandon said i think um
uh ravona will also be playing a like
[ __ ] i'm gonna come through and kill
all of them because i spent all this
time
thinking these three idols were my idols
and now it's just one man who
just doesn't care uh so i think and also
like ramona does have a lot to kill on
the fact that she was just like a little
high school or not little she was like
an elementary school teacher middle
school she was a school teacher and so
to have that like all taken away from
her and realize that her life is a lie
she would definitely go through killing
everyone so i could see her teaming up
with loki and moebius especially because
she felt this closest closeness with
mobius that she'd be like hey
i'm sorry i
i was following the wrong person so i
think i agree with brandon they're just
going to go through and kill all the
yeah do you think they'll ever put like
mobius and ravona together they were
kind of teasing it so much in the first
season okay i'm sorry but loki's not
bisexual for no reason i want loki to
get with mobius a hundred percent he can
have sylvie and mobius same time perfect
idea
he's gonna be so sad he's gonna get in
so he's gonna [ __ ] up so many missions
next season because he's gonna think
about her like that's my whole i love i
love love don't get me wrong but i hate
when you put it into a story line where
it causes the main character to just be
a freaking idiot we saw what happened to
the last of star wars movies i was
getting so [ __ ] mad i was like you
are human let's not blame love for that
i'm blaming love for the last star wars
movie uh the last one that came out not
the last one but like it i it's truly
just like once you give that character
that like
humanity which i is needed i'm like he's
gonna [ __ ] up everything he's gonna [ __ ]
up a mission he's gonna [ __ ] up
they're gonna be like walk quietly and
for some reason he's gonna be like
sylvie and stomp on the ground or
something stupid he's gonna do something
yeah
kind of played on his love in theory she
doesn't share it like he does he's like
the most loving loki in a lot of ways
our loki
loves hard and it it's sweet i love that
about her i love that she was like i
still like you like i'm affectionate
towards you but i'm not gonna let you
get in the way of my million-year like
mission like i have been jumping through
portals my entire life like you just got
here i've been doing this since i was
like five so
i love it i'm like be heartless be
heartless
the opposite of what like uh like you
know your traditional disney princesses
were brought up to do it's like i'm
gonna you know just
abandon my life
how it was before because i fell in love
but she's like nah i i just met you so
uh hopefully we will be cool after this
but i'ma stab this man anyway okay yeah
listen you do you i'm gonna stab this
guy anyway
these are all amazing theories i i
definitely do think that you know she
might be on a kill uh kang type of path
because um as we know from the upcoming
4-4 which is going to center around gore
the godbutcher who was angry at the gods
and celestial beings in the comics i
could definitely see a parallel there
with ravona rensslayer um just going
being mad against the gods that she
thought were real which was actually
kang
or he remains so yeah he she i could
totally see her um going about
throughout that but uh i could also see
a kiss kang scenario as well because
yeah precedent for that and she just
loves religion a lot and the whole
what it stands for so gotta kiss him to
kiss the pastor everybody step one you
get him step two you kiss him get him
um but let me ask you guys this what do
you guys think about you know we see
loki um potent uh go to a different sort
of tvas or at the end of loki
what do you think about the possibility
that loki went to the fox x-men universe
because we know that they're gonna be
more incorporated into the mcu in the
future oh this is like the fox's tva
yeah so like basically the fox's
timeline so like that's the fox morbius
that's the mobius sorry i keep saying
morgan so that would be the fox mobius
the fox b-52 and like
loki will be just be going through the
the x-men timeline in like a sort of
greatest moments type of in the fox
verse their names are morbius and b
their earth names for mobius and
whatever my mom gave me this name that's
my new head cannon you cannot take that
i would love that
uh but like do you guys think that
that's possible like would you guess it
would be a fun season too like that
would be so cool i didn't even think
about that that would be awesome the
reveal
can i do that can i declare you winner
but no i just think that it'd be a fun
way to sort of just like remind people
especially the youths we didn't grow up
around the glorious time that we did
when we first got to see the x-men um
pop off with uh you know wolverine um
hugh jackman first popping up on the
scene so like just getting to just
relive all those moments and like
getting all the casts back together
it'll be dope it'll be super dope i i
think it'll be fun it would be
interesting that like whatever kang has
taken over the tva
since he who remains is dead that king
is like no i'm obsessed with this one
timeline with all the fox mutants like
this is the one i'm trying to preserve
now i don't care about anything else i
just want to preserve these mutants he
saw days of future past in 2014 and was
like i need to go there they
probably have a great cafeteria there
too in the fox first let's go he's like
i gotta stop dark phoenix at all costs
whatever i do
i gotta stop it but like kang like
insists on dressing like the sixties
like they do in days of future past so
that king is just sixties kang who's
obsessed with the fox first okay sorry
oh my god i'm done i'll stop
also save darwin no get him dirty save
darwin yo for real i i keep saying this
yo it's a great opportunity i would
really love for darwin to materialize
within the mcu after he was killed in uh
first class they're so tired of us
asking for him they're gonna be like
he's not coming back
you guys deal with him dying immediately
he's not yeah like i just don't want to
see that meme on twitter anymore i i do
not want to see that twitter movie
anymore you guys deal with him putting
his head in a damn fish tank and then
swallowing lava that's all you get
inappropriate that's all you damn get
they're like we'll give you a hulu
series that's it okay
you get a hulu limited series with
darwin and then we're done and then
we're done
each 10 million rogue players oh my gosh
so many rug points my god
smart cookies but now it is time for our
rogue question are you guys ready i'm
waiting my body is ready my body is
ready so we have two suggestions here
you can pick whichever one you like more
you guys want a star trek question or a
sonic the hedgehog question uh
sonic the hedgehog okay i'm gonna do
sonic because that's what i wanted to do
okay i didn't know how star trek game
people were all right guys the sonic
cinematic universe is continuing to grow
with a third sonic movie already being
greenlit congratulations sonic little
buddy so in addition to that we're going
to get to the live action knuckle series
my little buddy
in addition to that we're going to get a
live action knuckle series on paramount
plus so pitch me your rogus ideas for a
knuckles spin-off show i would like it
if they did because it's still gonna be
idris elba voicing knuckles
uh who's very charming got a great voice
i'll give him two options i either want
to just continue doing luther and have
like knuckles show up in the next series
of luther yeah as like his like sidekick
for no don't explain it just like
knuckles is here to help you now and
it's like luther and knuckles working
together or like a travel show give me
the knuckles travel show where there's
no like action it's just like knuckles
going around eating foods meeting the
locals climbing up walls with his
knuckles and you know i don't know if
you guys have ever played uh like those
knuckles like search for the [ __ ]
emerald missions in in the video games
like sonic adventure 2 but like that's
essentially what that is it's like all
right let's just travel the world
looking for chaos emerald i mean i'm a
og knuckles i was there when the when
sonic and knuckles first drop you could
plug in your cartridge and play knuckles
on different games my favorite part of
the sonic 2 discourse is just that uh
i love that everyone is so mad that they
made knuckles too sexy
is that they're like knuckles is too
sexy with each other
focus on this movie man no like how
this week i'm disgusted well disgust how
dare she i just wanna i just wanna watch
sonic 2 without thinking about being fit
is that all i have that's why
is that too much to ask
that's impossible
that's the impossible that's incredible
if knuckles got a sideshow
um
i'd want it to be okay so this is
following the movie right i want it to
be like okay so you know how like lilo
and stitch got their spin-off series and
it was stitched trying to find all his
cousins all the alien cousins i wanted
to kind of be like that i wanted to be
um
knuckles and
sonic and tails looking for like the
rest of them um if there
go through a portal and figure out that
there's like real live versions of them
and then knuckles to see an echidna and
like punch the [ __ ] out of it
don't ever cut
[Laughter]
i really do love that idea of you know
knuckles searching for other people like
you know sonic in in entails and all
that because like that's sort of what
the whole sonic series was about
originally saving little animals from
you know being robots and all that so
yeah that's a really good idea
yeah that's really cool i like that what
you got for us whitney okay i want to
see the dark and gritty
uh knuckles
uh television series written by james
gunn in the style of peacemaker that's
what i want
i want to see idris
elbajo as knuckles just kicking ass i
want it to be full of 80s jams
i'm sorry i'm not ready to let
peacemaker go yet so that's probably why
i'm saying this because like me too oh
my god oh my god i'm like not ready for
it to be over i'm so sad that it was the
finale uh but that's what i want i want
to see the dark gritty james gun
knuckles reboot
oh you know what that's a good one punch
maker let's do it sonic franchise
definitely needs like full gore like
blood yeah
yeah oh yeah i mean like knuckles was
originally blue and then like the blood
of his enemies turned him around exactly
that's what i'm hearing from the lore
from the wicked emeralds drip with blood
i bathe the blood
that's an actual thing in real life
but these are all amazing theories i
love these theories out so much but i do
i love brandon's theory about him just
showing up on luthor because i just
think it's hilarious
and knuckles just talking the same just
have yeah you just have to work so much
for that show so i'm going to give
brandon 100 billion shajillion rogue
points making brandon our winner
brandon but you guys are all winners i
don't like giving winners because you
guys have the best theories you guys are
so creative and so smart when it comes
to nerdy things and i'm blessed to just
be able to talk to you guys every week i
love you guys
baby angel
oh thank you so much
uh but that is it for this episode of
rogue theory thank you to our guest
jessica clemons whitney van laningham
and off-screen producer brandon who runs
the world support our channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com and if
you've got thoughts on some of our rogue
theories you can share them on our
discord so if you're over 18 click the
link for the new rockstars discord
server in the description box below you
can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
really weird [ __ ] follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media but if
you do on youtube hit that notification
bell so you get notifications every time
we upload a video and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on youtube
thank you again for watching this video
we love you guys so much thank you so
much for spending time with us and we'll
see you guys next time goodbye
bye
[Music]
you